[Music]
Pioneers in the field of artificial
intelligence are pleading with Congress
to pass safety rules before it's too
late in fact yesterday the head of the
company that makes chat GPT warned a
possible significant harm to the world
if Washington doesn't set standards and
guard rails good luck Washington we're
all counting on you Scott McFarland has
the story
Alexa what's the weather like smart
speakers your GPS and robot vacuums were
just the start
artificial intelligence is growing at
warp speed I think it's important to
understand and think about gpd4 as a
tool not a creature and Sam Altman who
operates the surging chat GPT compared
AI to the invention of the printing
press at a U.S Senate hearing Tuesday
the promise of innovation comes with a
warning I think if this technology goes
wrong it can go quite wrong Congress is
concerned it risks waiting too long to
pass laws that will govern AI after
failing years ago to set rules for
social media we should be concerned for
our privacy we expect to be concerned
for our Liberty and that we should be
concerned for our control over our lives
so let's make sure that the tools
actually work for us and that we don't
end up working for the tools even the
industry is pushing for safety standards
we think that regulatory intervention by
governments will be critical to mitigate
the risks of increasingly powerful
models some of the initial possibilities
include government approval or safety
labels for future AI Innovations Plus
work programs so we need to train people
for the jobs of the future that will be
created but at the same time care for
people who will be put out of work
American colleges and universities
aren't waiting on Washington Morgan
State and Baltimore is among those that
have rolled out new AI curriculum now
you're going forward training students
how to find work in Ai and to ensure the
technology is safely deployed and
inclusive the technology is there it's
not going anywhere and I think we need
to also just have some diversity in how
we apply it
some members of Congress admit they
don't fully understand Ai and are taking
lessons on the hill Tony all right Scott
thank you very much